so there are two holidays coming up
Earth Day
Earth Day people liberals love birthday
that's Wednesday and the other holiday
is 4/20 now
do all you panelists number 420 is I'm a
little I'll take you on that let me
explain it to you Jeff thank you okay uh
no it's oh man up here no idea really
okay some years ago there was a bunch of
stoners at some high school I think it
was in California who got high every day
at 4:20 in the afternoon much like the
way the English drink tea at 4:00 yeah
that one my people drink bourbon at 5:00
okay so then 420 April 20th became kind
of a STONER holiday and we are trying to
get this to be a real holiday if you go
on HBO or HBO website hbo.com
there's the link there to change.org and
you can try to do that and you know
since 24 states now have marijuana being
legal in some form we think it should be
a real holiday you could get a Hallmark
card for it for sure
if it's more worthy than her Columbus
Day why should we celebrate that racist
psychopath so
I think non stoners may not realize that
we still on for 20 it's just like any
other holiday we have rituals we have
family over we've exchanged gifts we
have decorations we sing songs sterday
you just don't do anything is that like
we read twas the night before 4/20 would
you like to hear twas the night before
4/20 and all through the crib not a
creature was stirring not even did you
hear something with the door locks I was
wearing a t-shirt and shorts from the
gym I just settled down to watch adult
swim the bowls were all packed in the
Vegas with great care in the hopes
Willie Nelson so today when from out in
the yard came a crash in Abela whatever
it was it was arching my mellow
and what - my aunt wandering I should
appear it was a tall circus clown
molesting a deer
no no wait jut just a tree I've made a
mistake I guess I should mention I was
thoroughly baked then out of the shadows
I saw it myself it was Willie Nelson and
Snoop his jolly old elf
and a man who was grinning and wearing a
hoodie I know in an instant it was good
old Saint Woody I knew by their manner
in the lovely aroma that they'd all
brought me something to cure my glaucoma
and I heard them exclaim as the light
bathed them dimly bill you
stoner let us in you don't have a
chimney we lit up a joint and ate a pot
brownie and soon were as high as a young
Robert Downey went out on the lawn I
heard such a crash I ran to the toilet
to flush all our stash I looked at the
people and what did I spot the Chief of
Police at 8:00 angry cops and then in a
twinkling I heard overhead a fully armed
SWAT team I thought we were dead then
they all flew like Easter a fog they
barked out commands and shot my poor dog
but he'll be ok they were after a
pothead who matched my description but I
reached in my pocket and pulled out my
prescription
they looked at it closely they began to
wine into gross but they knew they had
nothing so I said get out of my house I
said you don't have a warrant you don't
have a rich happy 4:22 wall and to all
some good